welcome in to another edition of Market
takes like I know you could have been
anywhere in the world but you were here
with me and I appreciate that I am Dion
rabone reporter at the Wall Street
Journal and you know there's a lot going
on this week in the world of markets and
economics but I'm going to tell you the
three most important things you need to
be watching out for this week and it is
a big one look this week we got the CPI
report Consumer Price Index the
inflation report that uh that's really
most dedicated to what's going on with
consumers you and me what we're doing
what we're spending and how we're
spending that report is going to show us
where inflation has landed we get that
tomorrow we will be right here for
Market takes I hope you'll be with us
Wednesday the Federal Reserve meets the
fomc policy rate decision that's going
on on Wednesday we'll be right here
again on Market takes at 4 pm hope
you'll join us then as well and then
Thursday we've got retail sales so we're
going to break down what all those are
what you should be watching for each one
of those reports let's start with CPI I
want to put a chart up here on your
screen just kick things off with that
now we have seen inflation cooling since
the middle of 2022 now you see there on
your screen the chart Rising you see
those bars getting higher reach nine
percent in June and ever since then
really inflation has been coming down on
the CPI but you've seen there towards
the end uh the bars not really moving
significantly lower you see a defined
lower numbers on each of those bars and
then the last couple months have been
right around five percent five percent
definitely lower than nine percent but
very far from the fed's two percent
Target which it you know we're seeing a
more than double so again worrying that
inflation could be stuck at this five
percent level is what's got some
Economist little worry about that and
that chart just illustrating like we
said that inflation had been coming down
consistently but it stalled out there
and if it continues to stall out that
could be trouble that could mean the
fed's got to do more raise interest
rates even more do more to choke off and
sort of slow down the economy economists
however are expecting that CPI is going
to come down five to four percent uh for
this month or at least for last month in
the report that we get this month uh
four percent which would be very bullish
for the market and definitely bullish
for stocks recent data however has
suggested that that inflation cooling
Trend that we have seen for most this
year could be slowing we've seen uh home
sales starting to pick up particularly
new home sales I'll reach the highest
since March 2022 last month we've also
seen a housing permits pick up and home
builder confidence actually reached a 10
month High last month we have also seen
inventory of expected homes 44 percent
lower than it was pre-pandemic or 44
lower than their pre-pandemic levels
we're also seeing business activity
rising to a 13-month high according to
the s p purchasing manager's index and
retail sales uh Rising surprisingly last
month when we expected a decline we will
talk more about that in just a moment so
all these things have suggested the
consumer continues to go out and spend
folks are still spending money even
though prices are still rising at a
pretty fast clip remember five percent
inflation is still much faster than
anything we have seen in the past 20
years or so so Prof or so price is still
continuing to rise and also those net
profit margins we saw for q1 now that
we've seen about 99 of s p 500 companies
report their earnings we have seen
profit margins rise again uh for most of
those companies in Q in q1 if you want
to continue to see growth for companies
they usually have to continue to keep
raising those prices in Q2 so we will
see if that is continued definitely CPI
will be a report to keep your eye on
also you'll want to watch core CPI that
number has been high higher while we've
seen CPI continue to come down core CPI
has held higher usually you need core
CPI to come down or the FED starts to
get worried definitely something you'll
want to watch out for which brings us to
of course the next big thing to watch
this week that is the fomc policy mainly
Federal open markets committee that's
where they decide what they're going to
do about rates now this month it's not
about the actual decision it's not about
is the Fed gonna raise rates or not the
market is convinced the FED is going to
stop the question is is that a pause or
a skip are they stopping because they're
they're going to hold rates here at this
level or are they just pausing really
quickly and then going to start raising
them again starting in July the market
is not quite certain about that we're
locked in for a pause this week but when
we get the summary of economic
projections The Dot Plot when we get
when we see the statement and we hear
from Fed chair Jerome Powell that's
what's going to move the market so
you're going to watch out for those and
again we will be with you after that to
break down everything that was said and
everything that happened we've seen some
disagreement coming into this meeting
some fed officials say say look
inflation's starting to pick back up
they point to those home sales number
they point to the jobs growth they point
to some of these other Data Business
sentiment and all that and they say
listen inflation's going to pick back up
we've got to be proactive even if we
stop here we've got to start raising
again in July while some other fed
officials say no we may have already
done too much we've got to pause we've
got to make clear to the market that
we're not going to do too much and
really send the country into a needless
and unnecessary avoidable recession so
that's what you've got coming in CPI
will be a big determinant of what that
is and how fed officials respond and
then we're going to hear from them on
Wednesday so we are going to get a
chance to see what they say and hear
what what they think and then of course
we'll hear from the chairman at 2 30 on
Wednesday markets no longer pricing in
multiple rate Cuts this year in fact
markets are pricing in a rate hike in
July and then after that we'll see and
we're going to get a lot of clarity on
what that is going to be from the market
want to show you one more quick thing
put a chart up here on your screen and
this right here what you're seeing is
the former Fang stocks no longer called
fang obviously Facebook is now meta
Google is now alphabet but these big
tech companies that's alphabet Apple uh
Netflix and video some of those bigger
names that you've seen this chart is
actually made up of apple snow AMD Tesla
Amazon Netflix Microsoft Google but you
see that major significant out
performance there of those stocks those
big Tech names up about 50 percent over
the past year when you when you bring it
into just so far year to date starting
from January those stocks have risen
more than 70 percent while the equal
weighted S P 500 the s p is weighted by
uh the biggest companies have the
biggest weights but if you take that out
and you say okay all 500 companies in
the S P 500 have the same weighting well
that index has not risen but about one
percent so far this year and that is a
significant difference from what we've
seen from Big Tech which is what leads
the index and that's Rising by about 70
year to date so this charge is
illustrating the significant difference
in overall performance of the market
those big Tech names having a huge year
uh the rest of the market not really
kind of being left behind last thing we
want to talk about is U.S retail sales I
want to put one more chart up here
actually we've got two more charts but
first let's put this chart up here on
your screen this is the month over month
change in retail sales now if you look
on that chart you can see four of the
last six months have been negative and
you're seeing a very choppy movement
right you're seeing some months retail
sales are down some months they're up
now I want to compare that to let's show
you the year over year change in retail
sales well there you get a much more
clear picture of what's been happening
retail sales have been slowing down
consistently year over year when you
look at it we're seeing a Slowdown now
to about two and a half percent was the
last reading and this does not factor in
inflation so this is just how much
people are spending compared to the year
before so even though prices are going
up and overall sales are increasing
right you're seeing more sales because
prices are higher it's just about how
much money was brought in well you're
seeing a decline in retail sales so even
though we've still got inflation up five
percent last month you saw retail sales
only about two and a half percent and
that shows you that you're seeing a
defined and clear slowdown of the
consumer how much does that continue or
how much is that Trend change we will
find out on Thursday and that chart just
illustrating what we had seen from
retail sales coming in so will consumers
continue to spend how will the FED react
to the CPI data and what will the CPI
inflation data tell you we will find all
that out this week it is a big week the
rubber meeting the road in a big way so
listen that's going to do it for us here
on Market takes thank you so much for
looking forward to the week uh with me
I'm Dion rabone reporter at the Wall
Street Journal we will be with you
tomorrow morning at 10 A.M breaking down
the CPI report I hope you'll be with us
when we do it again next time